My grandfather is being deported.
Wait, like, deported deported?
To Mexico.
At least there'sCancún.
I mean, that's a nice beach.
ana You have to say "undocumented."
Judge Corchado?
This guy's tough.
Judge Judy tough
or Ana María Polo tough?
Has his huevitos
with a side of Fox News.
I'll do everything I have to do
to make sure
that my father has a better life,
here or in Mexico.
Next.
-You gonna order or what?
-Yeah. Sorry.
Damn!
Y'all are freaks!
I'm here for Pop. Not for you.
I'm at this point in my life
where I choose to be
with the ones who choose me.
Just gonna leave your papi chulo
like that? Not you,cochino.
I just think
maybe we need space.
This isn't the food
or the amazing sex talking.
You're a natural chef.
It's the amazing sex talking
a little, right?
-You want a hit?
-Hell yeah.
Homie, we're about to enter
a new dimension.
Spend as much time
with each other
as you possibly can.
And enjoy each other.
-Slow down.
-What do you mean, "slow down"?
I don't know what this is.
Ana, do it like you mean it.
-Girl.
-Come on, Ana.
That'll do.